330 respaldos iluminaciones esto es un
tema de mediciones
y de los 330
ganamos 200 ganamos 300 y 324
Entonces
si creen que 2004 algunas de esas fueron
difíciles hay que decirlo
hubo mucha gente que pasó del quinto
lugar al primero pero bueno fueron 224
de 330 creo que su número bastante
importante y hoy porque seguían diciendo
no él tiene nominaciones pero será que
va a irle bien en las elecciones
generales en este momento
tenemos algunas cifras hay 80 victorias
y 30 derrotas es eso bien está bien
hechizosísimo que nos fuera mejor en el
tema de las elecciones está muy bien
Carolina del Norte
está liderando la carrera 51 a 47%. en
Missouri un gran tipo de Richmond está
arriba al 55 43
y está en contra de un bus pero es un
bus distinto
es una gran diferencia díganme ustedes
Cuál es el bus real real
ahora está liderando 52 a 47 tuvimos
vieron que en Florida ganó marco Rubio
tuvimos un encuentro increíble para
marco la noche justo antes con la peor
lluvia que había visto estaba ahí y fue
hermoso todo lo que vieron bueno
y de repente se pusieron absurdamente
oscuro y era como si hubiera
grandes Fuentes que cayeron encima de
nosotros
teníamos 40.000 personas no había ningún
tipo y dije Bueno me pregunto qué haría
byden ahora
tengo una noche increíble
felicitarla la respaldamos también
se fue bastante bien 68 a 30 significa
que ya tienen futuro y
Posiblemente sea el ser humano más
grande físicamente conocido podría ser
un fue un linero ofensivo de la NFL jugó
para Alabama
felicitaciones
está liderando su carrera en estos
momentos
tenemos
muchas
carreras electorales disfruten de eso
disfruten de la comida disfruten de todo
por favor Y con toda justicia es un gran
honor tener a los medios con nosotros
Espero que ustedes disfruten también
con este grupo maravillosa de personas
Esta es la gente de la que ustedes leen
bueno no son las mejores personas pero
son brillantes financieramente no vamos
a ver grandes figuras del fútbol
americano pero veremos gente brillante
son gente maravillosa gente muy exitosa
ellos quieren lo que es bueno para el
país por eso es que están acá quiero
agradecerle a todos por estar acá de
nuevo a los medios Muchas gracias tengan
una buena noche gracias
[Aplausos]